people try to say well you should try to
learn 10 words a day and really make
sure you can use them and sort of nail
them down
i've never found that effective hi there
steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about
learning vocabulary and why we shouldn't
try to remember vocabulary now if you
enjoy my videos please subscribe click
on the bell for notification if you
follow me on a podcast service please
leave a comment so
i mentioned the other day that i went to
visit my brother who's not well he's
sort of bedridden i gave him an ipad and
i tried to get him going on link so it's
very interesting for me and i speak to
him every couple of days it's very
interesting for me to see his experience
because he's not an experienced language
learner and so he's
learning link and he's getting used to
learning in his case spanish using link
and so he said to me on several
occasions you know i keep on trying to
remember
this sentence or this word and i can't
remember it then it's quite frustrating
and so i
tried to explain to him again that
you know don't worry about not
remembering in fact don't even try to
remember the vocabulary keep moving keep
moving on and eventually the words will
start to stick
and i thought of my own process of
language learning
and
i mean the bulk of my words i learn them
through listening and reading
um
i look words up every time like if i'm
on my lesson page in link if it's a blue
word obviously i look it up in order to
get the meaning it's now a yellow word
but when i come across a yellow word
even if i kind of think i know the
meaning i'll just give another quick
look
and then of course that doesn't mean i
can use it it doesn't mean that i won't
again have to look it up the next time
but it's part of that gradual process of
getting a sense of
what the scope of meaning of the word is
as i see it in different contexts
getting familiar with the word
the word getting familiar with me
and and at some point it starts to click
in and it's very hard to predict when
that's going to happen
and so most of my activity is listening
and reading
noticing things while reading noticing
things while listening but i also do
review
words in lists
uh and i've said that i'll sometimes
pick you know the status three the sort
of familiar words to try and move some
to known to pad my
known words
number
uh
i'll sometimes look at them in
alphabetical order just to see the words
that have the same
you know prefix because that can help
if i do flashcards i want all the
information
on the face of the flashcard it's all
just exposure
i don't try to rack my brain in other
words have the either the word in the
target language on the front of the
flash card and then try to think what it
means and flip it over or conversely to
see say the english word and try to
remember what that is
in the target language i don't do those
things some people do i'm not saying
that it's not effective for some people
but for me
i don't believe in it i i feel that if i
can continue to expose
myself or expose these words to my brain
in different ways eventually i will
learn them and i have noticed that
a lot of the words that i learn that are
added to my known words total
are words that i didn't even look up
because words
you know they have things in common and
pretty soon we
know
uh maybe a different tense or a
different person or a different form of
a word that we've already learned
and so without even looking that word up
it's just added to our known words total
because we didn't save it and so the
system considers it known so
i sometimes feel that this sort of
deliberate attempt
to acquire words and and what's
particularly bad is is is it people try
to say well you should try to learn 10
words a day and really make sure you can
use them and sort of nail them down
i've never found that effective i i far
rather
just expose myself to as many words as i
can
rereading old lessons
you know going into new lessons
exposing myself to these words and
gradually lo and behold the statistics
in increase and my known words total all
of a sudden it's 10 000 words
granted the way we count them at link
where each form of the word is
considered a different word
but
the point is
don't in my view don't rely on memory
like a lot of people say to me well i
can't learn languages because
uh i have a poor memory
your poor memory is probably not that
poor it's irrelevant language learning
is not about
memorization language learning is about
committing yourself to a process
enjoying the process
allowing the language to come into you
and trusting that your brain will
gradually understand more and more
gradually acquire more and more words so
my advice on language learning or in
terms of acquiring words and i should
say
accumulating words is the fundamental
task in language learning and so the
more words you have even passively the
better your potential in the language so
it is important to acquire the words but
you're not necessarily going to acquire
words by deliberately trying to remember
them
a couple of videos i'll leave you with
one where i talk about learning 100
words a day
and another one where i talk about
memorization and language learning i did
these a few years ago
hopefully i said the same things then as
i'm saying now
thank you for listening bye for now